[Music]
sunday morning in the garduno and so
ends another liverpool adventure
but the postcard from paris doesn't read
well
it was
the worst experience of my life it was
absolutely horrible absolute disgrace
to shambolic it seems to me that the
people who should be organizing this are
probably sat in a corporate lounge with
their other corporate friends with the
other sixty thousand people who've got
corporate tickets and the twenty
thousand actually spent hard earned
money to get there are the ones that are
just left outside their own devices no
problem no one was pushing no one was
shoving and the police and the gates
were closed
children
people in wheelchairs even got tear
gassed
it was lucky enough i was in early but i
watched it all and it was just
heavy-handed throwing people to the
floor
it was horrendous
on saturday night this was two hours
before kickoff
fans complained of crushing as they were
held back by a police
the crowd was eventually allowed to
proceed but chaotic scenes continued
closer to the ground
this was how it looked on the stadium
concourse
there was a robust police operation in
riot gear to prevent unauthorized entry
using pepper spray and tear gas
uefa said thousands of people had turned
up with fake tickets
caught in the middle of it all were
liverpool fans made to queue until half
time to get in
there was no single factor behind the
events at the start of france but many
liverpool fans have questioned the role
in this affair of local people who'd
gathered in numbers around the stadium
and who they say were in the liverpool
end during the match
the game itself saw victory for real
madrid junior scoring the only goal in
59 minutes to win a 14th champions
league trophy for the spanish champions
inside the defeated dressing room
thoughts quickly turned to events
outside
it's not been well organized
and you know you
you have to have some sympathy because
obviously it's been kind of thrown on
paris kind of last minute wherefore it's
been on as a ue for competition is the
biggest game in world football which
should be um it should be organized a
lot better than the leagues like that
shouldn't be happening and definitely
the force that was used probably tonight
by certain authorities shouldn't be used
it shouldn't be happening either
it wasn't just that the stadium where
supporters endured a torrid night
this was the scene at a fan park in the
centre of town where liverpool fans had
gathered and found themselves targeted
by tear gas as police cleared the area
as liverpool fans head home the club has
called for a formal investigation into
the events of saturday night but for too
many in this travelling support lessons
learned will be too late
[Applause]
back in liverpool an open-top bus parade
to lighten the mood
this team has made memories this season
and won't forget the highs even if the
lows hang heavy
they can always hail trophy success in
england
sadly they'll always have parents
james matthews sky news in paris